besagtes menschenleben sind in gefahr
dort auf diesem campingplatz sind dort
noch viele menschen jetzt sehen wir auch
bilder wie die menschen ja in tüten ihr
hab und gut zusammen packen und von den
beamten heraus gebracht werden alles
kommentiert bitte diese bilder für uns
live jetzt was passiert dort gerade
genau ja jetzt läuft gerade eine
durchsage der polizei vielleicht hören
wir dass die haben einen lautsprecher in
der hand und wir schauen wir gehen mal
jetzt einmal zu der polizei hin wie die
maßnahme hier abläuft ein lautsprecher
mit mikrofonen rufen sie dass sie der
campingplatz geräumt werden soll und die
leute verlassen einzeln diesen platz und
auf der anderen seite wenn der
kameramann jetzt einmal die seite
durchsagen der polizei räumen die kämpfe
ich und wir sehen jetzt wie akut das
ganze ist die feuerwehr hat von einem
der campingplatz leuten ein segel
das ist kein segelboote ein kanu
ausgeliehen und wird jetzt gleich die
bereiche die sie nicht mehr einfach so
erreichen kann mit diesem kanu ihr
ansteuern und versuchen und zu gucken ob
da noch leute sind also das sind
wirklich eher angespannte bilder
dramatische bilder die uns jetzt gerade
hier erreichen
jede minute jede sekunde kann es sein
dass dieser bereich meterhoch unter
wasser steht das heißt alex das wasser
breitet sich da im moment noch aus also
werden wir gerade von einigen kollegen
beispielsweise aus wuppertal gehört da
steigt das was da nicht weiter da gibt
so langsam die hoffnung dass sich das
wasser zurück zieht das betrifft weite
teile in nordrhein-westfalen eben
überhaupt nicht sondern da ist die
katastrophe gerade erst doch im anmarsch
richtig dass das ist wirklich so also
die schleusen werden aufgemacht und wir
sehen wie akut das ganze ist als die
polizei die hosen hochgekrempelt hat und
mit ihren dienst schon hier durch das
wasser läuft das zeigt dass das ganze
wirklich eine ernste lage ist und ja
lange das läuft und wann diese
wassermassen hier hoch kommen das ist
noch unklar
alexej kannst du noch mal versuchen das
ist eben gerade beschrieben dass die
polizei da ein kanu hat und jetzt quasi
wenn ich dich richtig verstehe den plan
hat diesen campingplatz mal abzufahren
um auch zu schauen ob die menschen dort
die dort eigentlich urlaub machen
wollten
auch dieser aufforderung die gerade eben
per lautsprecher kam den campingplatz zu
räumen
auch folgen oder ob sie die auch
überhaupt gehört haben vielleicht hast
du die möglichkeit mit einem der beamten
zu sprechen und uns einen einblick zu
geben wie jetzt in dieser situation dort
auf diesem campingplatz wagen
vorgegangen wird
also ich will einmal sagen dass wir
wirklich auch bis an die grenzen gehen
also bestehen selbst knietief im wasser
und die polizei ist jetzt alles klar die
polizei teilt gerade mit dass hier
dieser bereich für uns auch jetzt endet
weil die strömung zu tief zu reißerisch
ist und man sieht es vielleicht im
hintergrund dass die ruhe wirklich eine
harte strömung hat und wir sehen jetzt
hier
wenn der kameramann noch zwei schritte
nach vorne kommt sehen wir gerade dass
die polizei samt kanu und evakuierte
campingplatz leute in unsere richtung
kommt in sicherheit gebracht wird ja das
sind aktuelle bilder aus hagen vom
campingplatz an der ruhr wir sind bild
und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren